[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
choisir toutes vos idées sorties
culturelles ou sportives dans le
département merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro tout de suite le
sommaire de ce vendredi 6 octobre des
nouveautés cette année au parc de thoiry
envolez-vous au dessus des lions et
partez au coeur de la réserve collombat
de lapanouse directrice générale
adjointe du parc nous donnera plus de
détails sur ces animations
l'occasion aussi d'évoquer les nouvelles
venues des bébés yen mais fin septembre
sans oublier halloween qui se prépare
découvrez la lumière et les illusions
d'optique à l'aide d'expériences pour
notre rendez-vous junior mélanie poker
nous présentera l'exposition manip
installé à la verrière dans le cadre de
la fête de la science et nous
accueillons justement mélanie poquet et
collombat de la panne ou sur le plateau
bonjour à toutes les deux bonjour alors
mélanie nous parlerons science un petit
peu plus tard dans l'émission j'ai
d'abord une petite question pour vous
n'avez vous jamais rêvé de contempler
les anime les animaux vue du ciel ou
bien de les approcher à quelques mètres
à les abroger ce sera un peu plus
compliqué j'ai eu assez peur des animaux
mais les sciences voile et pourquoi pas
en tout cas pour beaucoup c'est un rêve
devenu réalité depuis cet été de
nouvelles activités ont fait leur
apparition au parc de thoiry un vol en
tyrolienne et un camion safari et avant
d'en parler avec vous que l'on bat de
lapanouse
je vous propose une immersion avec un
reportage de david charpentier et les
arènes on n'avait pas très bien
on va passer dessus on va l'entendre
effet pas très bien c'est un grand coup
franc versé par vécu c'est parti pour
une visite guidée en camion safari d'une
heure tout au long du parcours le guide
donne des explications et anecdotes sur
le lieux traversés
ce peut être la forêt des houches le
territoire des lions ou encore l'appeler
l'africaine
alors messieurs vous pouvez voir la même
couleur
il ya au cultura qui a le même type de
tâche g20 toussaint ferrand 63 respect
jura différentes
une balade en voiture qui permet aux
petits comme aux grands de pouvoir
toucher des yeux des animaux jusque là
invisible donc il ya également des
animaux visible supplémentaires par
rapport au fait de venir avec sa voiture
dont par exemple les lions qui
normalement ne sont pas dans la visite
en voiture et du coup ça nous permet de
nous d'avoir un regard sur les visiteurs
et d'éviter qu'ils fassent qu'ils
fassent n'importe quoi les choses
dangereuses par exemple
l'autre grande nouveauté du parc la
tyrolienne géante composée de deux trous
sont de 250 mètres chacun la tyrolienne
peut atteindre les 20 mètres de hauteur
[Musique]
toutes les personnes qui l'ont fait
aujourd'hui sont pleinement satisfaites
parce que ça change un petit peu du
quotidien de la visite au zoo et puis on
peut observer des animaux d'une autre
manière surtout les lions et certains
animaux de la réserve africaine
il n'est dit sortez vos doudounes et
bonnet cette année le domaine de thoiry
propose une ouverture hivernale jusqu'au
7 janvier 2018
ces activités sont donc proposés tous
les week-ends sous réserve de météo
clémente pour la tyrolienne bien sûr et
grande nouveauté justement cette année
la fermeture hivernale a lieu plus tard
collombat de lapanouse
on peut encore en profiter jusqu'au
janvier ça vient ça c'est bien ça
jusqu'au 7 janvier
on peut profiter les week-end et durant
les vacances de noël et un tarif spécial
sera mis en place sa de novembre tout à
fait dire à un tarif réduit dès qu'on a
fermé la pleine ouverture et qu'on
serait ouvert plus que les week-ends
mais pendant les vacances de noël dont
se rouvrir tous les jours et comment
vous est venue l'idée de créer alors sa
nouvelle animation cette tyrolienne au
dessus des lions ce camion safari alors
va être le parc de thoiry 1 2 puis de
tout le tout début en mai 68 ça a
toujours été vraiment l'immersion c'est
ce qui nous différenciait des autres
parcs le camion safari permet d'abord
d'avoir une visite guidée avec un
soigneur qui connaît bien les animaux et
d'aller au plus proche des animaux parce
qu'on fait du hors piste et en plus on
peut aller dans le territoire des lions
ce que les voitures ne font pas
d'habitude donc on pousse plus loin
encore l'immersion au milieu de la
réserve africaine et la tyrolienne
pareil c'est le même principe sauf qu'on
est un oiseau dans les airs et on
survole les animaux d'en haut notamment
les lions mais aussi les antilopes que
les choses par différents points de vue
pour les modalités à préciser qu'à un
supplément sur le prix des baigneurs
aient demandé tout à fait 6 8 euros pour
le cameroun et c'est 6 euros pour la
tyrolienne
tout simplement parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de personnel déjà pour le camion passait
une visite guidée de 1h15 donc bon et la
tyrolienne effectivement il ya des
paramètres de sécurité très contraignant
à respecter mais ça c'est normal la
sécurité du public avant tout donc ça
nécessite quatre personnes pour qu'une
personne puisse faire le parcours en
tyrolienne et au zoo de thoiry vous avez
également accueilli des nouvelles venues
dernièrement des post-it y est menée fin
septembre tout à fait on est deux petits
tiennent donc c'est la deuxième porte et
pour shendi
autre femelle qui avait déjà eu une
portée l'année dernière donc là ils sont
vraiment en tout petit dans quelques
jours mais ils sont déjà très actifs
parce que le yen sont des animaux qui
d'une société très hiérarchisée et donc
dès le début par les petits doivent se
défendent pour déjà marqué leur place
prendre leur place et là le rôle dans la
parc zoologique comme thoiry qu'apporte
ce type de naissance justement ça
sensibilise aussi beaucoup le public à
la protection d'environnement on imagine
bien sûr pas la vocation première d'un
parc zoologique c'est de sensibiliser
les gens à la nature et la
sensibilisation aux problématiques de la
protection de l'environnement
ça passe d'abord par l'empathie et c'est
sûr que les petits bonds les visiteurs
tout le monde nous si on adore voir les
petits c'est vraiment tordant et ça
permet voilà de créer ce lien affectif
qui nous permet ensuite d'amener les
gens à avoir une réflexion réelle sur la
protection de la biodiversité
on va voir un petit peu plus loin parce
que qui dit octobre dit bien sûr à nos
mines et le parc de thoiry ne fait pas
exception à la règle de vous allez
organiser des animations pour le
visiteur dès le 21 octobre tout à fait
le 21 et le 22 octobre ce week-end nas
et les animations pour les enfants
alors là il s'agit de trouver l'énigme
magique pour pouvoir s'en sortir et
après le du 27 au 31 octobre il y aller
murder party pour les adultes ça ça fait
un petit peu plus peur alors vous voyez
on connaîtrait pas la murder party c'est
comme un cru dauger en exactement il
faut trouver qui est le meurtrier il ya
une victime et il y à des fantômes qui
brouille les pistes très bien on va aux
amateurs pour ceux qui veulent des
sensations fortes ou en tout cas
profiter des animaux merci beaucoup que
l'on bat de lapanouse il est revenu sur
notre plateau et les informations sur le
disait de sur les différentes animations
proposées par le parc de thoiry sont à
retrouver sur le site internet merci
beaucoup d'en bas de la planète merci
sortez vos baskets et votre vélo samedi
7 octobre c'est la run and bike à
plaisir troisième édition de cette
compétition qui mêle course à pied et
cyclisme
vous pouvez participer entre amis ou en
famille mais en tous les cas en binôme
possibilité de s'inscrire sur place
avant le début de la première course à
8h30
il y en a pour tous les niveaux de la
course à la randonnée familiale
vous avez quatre courses une course de
15 km qui démarre le matin une course de
sept kilomètres et demi pour les adultes
et puis aussi pour les les ados et puis
après vous avez deux courses 2,4 et 2,2
km pour les enfants ainsi qu'une course
m'a alors celle là elle est vraiment on
l'a fait part par pur loisir c'est une
course pour les parents pour les
familles et tout le week-end c'est aussi
la sixième édition des dialogues au
jardin un événement national auquel
participent les jardins de la vallée à
magny les hameaux le thème de cette
année cocooning au jardin l'entreprise
de paysagistes fait également ses 20 ans
des conférences des ateliers et des
animations pour les enfants sont
proposés
de quoi donner quelques idées pour
aménager son extérieur on va avoir des
cuisine d'extérieur aménagé avec des
cheminées d'extérieur avec des tables
pour
pour ce bien bien bien mettre en valeur
les soirées très sympa qu'on peut
organiser avec ses amis dans un jardin
on met en valeur aussi les pool house et
c'est que on peut trouver maintenant
dans des jardins et qui sont finalement
et qui peuvent être des ateliers
d'artistes au sein même du jardin
finalement maintenant c'est presque la
maison qui vient dans le jardin est pas
là et pas l'inversé
[Musique]
c'était le thème avec notre invité la
semaine dernière la fête de la science à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération participent à cet
événement national organisé par le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
ça a commencé le 30 septembre avec avec
différentes animations à saint quentin
ont fait le point avec mélanie pocket
j'allais dire ça commence et que mélanie
poker et non pas encore faudrait
peut-être penser non en fait camion va
s'intéresser une animation en
particulier une exposition manip autour
de la lumière et des illusions d'optique
déjà camilla vous avez fait une question
tout à l'heure je vous imposer un bon
tour est ce que vous savez ce qu'est une
illusion d'optique
je veux dire joker non je dirais que
c'est quelque chose que notre oeil pour
voir mais qui n'est pas tout à fait vrai
bon elle repose on a vérifié je préfère
ne rien dire non plus antoine vignal
chargée d'action culturelle de l'atelier
des sciences nous donne sa définition
c'est quelque chose qui nous semblent
réels mais ne l'est pas à une illusion
d'optique contrairement à ce qu'on pense
pas une illusion créée par l'oeil c'est
une illusion qu'on voit mais qui crée
par le cerveau notre cerveau lui va
créer en fait un une logique à tout ça
va créer l'image que l'on voit mais des
fois justement le cerveau se tromper
créer une logique là où il n'y en a pas
l exposition est actuellement à la
médiathèque aimé-césaire de la verrière
mais elle est inhérente
alors elle reste à la verrière jusqu'au
15 octobre elle prendra ensuite la
direction de trappes elle passera à
elancourt pour prendre fin en décembre à
guyancourt
alors toutes les dates sont précisées
sur le site internet de cases qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
ça ce sont les informations pratiques
pour l'exposition plus précisément elle
s'intéresse à la lumière sous toutes ses
formes
écoutez on va vraiment abordé le thème
de la lumière mais sous à toutes ces
propriétés
on va passer la lumière dans la nature
la lumière le principe de des fractions
de diffusion de la lumière de
déformation la lumière de décomposition
de la lumière
vraiment on va apporter toutes les
propriétés physiques de la lumière aussi
en passant par le côté artistique
l exposition est composée de panneaux
mais pas que pas que parce qu'à chaque
panneau qu'émilie à une manipulation qui
est proposé pour comprendre ce qui est
expliqué il y en a des simples à
réaliser des cinq six ans certaines sont
un peu plus con un peu plus complexe
parce qu'elle s'adresse à un public
plutôt lycéens
alors qu'amy je voudrais aussi terminé
sur un autre et vernant événement
toujours la fête de la science
l'ouverture officielle c'est à
l'estaminet de magny les hameaux que ça
se passe avec l'astro club de magnitude
6 1 18 des séances de planétarium vous
attendent dès l'âge de 50
merci mélanie pour ce petit point
scientifique sur les illusions d'optique
et on termine cette émission par un
dernier rendez vous à noter
[Musique]
une nuit entièrement consacré au jeu
sous toutes leurs formes jeux de société
de stratégie jeux vidéo ou escape game
petits et grands sont attendus au muy
m'aide à montigny le bretonneux pour la
première demie du jeu samedi 7 octobre
l'entrée est gratuite
c'est la fin de ce set 8 loisirs merci
de nous avoir suivis j'espère que vous
avez fait le plein d'idées sorties pour
le week end ou pour la semaine à venir
je vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour
un nouveau numéro excellent week end et
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
oh